melissa thanks for doing this thanks
conan thanks for having me
we have a lot to talk about i've been
wanting to talk to you for a while
uh you've been obviously killing it on
senate live
you're so funny uh you do such amazing
impressions
the latest i'm told is lin manuel
miranda you're working on a lin manuel
miranda
this is you in your uh
in your makeup as lin-manuel miranda and
if i'm not mistaken you just took a
ballpoint pen
is that what you did well no no no that
that is an
eyeliner and i i always know that it
looks really good
i mean it doesn't look realistic but i'm
saying that's that's all i had on me
okay
okay okay no i i like it i'm just going
to tell you
in real life and you probably have to
i've i've spent time with lin-manuel
miranda and in real life he uses a
ballpoint pen
oh okay but yeah so that's what he does
and he just fills it in throughout the
day what is the key
to i don't know that i've heard someone
do a lin manuel miranda impression
what's the key
how do you hone in on that well i i was
thinking about it
the way he he sings it sounds like he's
in the sea and he's drowning okay and
he's telling a boat nearby
he's saying please have me a lifesaver
i'm drowning i just want to live with
you
and so that's all right or he's slipping
off a
a um a rope maybe
no i i love you don't let go
[Laughter]
do you sing some of the actual songs
that he sings in hamilton
i i i have been singing my shot but the
problem is i don't know
all the lyrics but i want to sing it
real fast like he does
right i was trying to sing it to my
sister the other day i was like
i'm not throwing away my shot i am not
throwing away my
shot and you're just like my country i'm
young scruffy and homie and i said homie
and she's
me hungry it's hungry it's hungry
[Music]
have you tried this out on lin-manuel
miranda um
nobody saw i i shared a photo of that oh
no the video of me
i went to i drove through a uh a coffee
place and i said i'll take a
cold brew with a shot and then i
filmed it was so stupid but he he
messaged her and he laughed so that
those are my favorite
my favorite impressions are the silly
ones do you know what i mean
yeah it's just like you're using it in a
completely ridiculous absurd way
getting uh getting a starboard starbucks
order